yes great um so thank you to the
speakers for those great talks they were
super interesting
um and uh hopefully this half hour we
can get some
some more answers and perhaps some more
questions and perhaps some
collaborations
um so one thing that came to mind as as
i was
listening to all those talks is that
you could think of imitation learning
as a type of offline rl in the sense
that you're getting
a set of data a batch of data from from
an expert
and you're trying to leverage this data
to to learn how to act near optimally
or at least close to the experts
and so one of the recurring themes that
i felt
uh kept coming up throughout the talks
is this need to balance
um coverage of the uh or this need to
have coverage of the state in action
space
so that you can have be certain of your
estimates and i'm i was wondering your
thoughts
on um how you balance this
trade-off of more coverage versus sample
efficiency and by sample efficiency
i mean the amount of data you require in
order to be able to do offline rl
well um how this balance is handled in
the offline rl literature versus
uh in the imitation learning literature
i don't know whoever wants to uh take
the the question
i didn't wasn't directed at anyone in
particular i'd be interested in all of
your opinions i believe sergey's hand is
raised
uh so i can take a stab at it although i
might miss the point of your
question a little bit but let me let me
give it a shot um
so i think something lurking in that
question is
is uh maybe a little bit of a difference
in how
the world looks when we imagine the
problem
as one where you have small data sets in
small state spaces versus when you have
enormous data sets with very diverse
things going on and i think in those
cases
these things look a little different so
if you uh
even though mathematically they're very
similar so if you look at the world in
terms of sort of small data sets and
small
state spaces you might imagine well what
we need to do is we need to see
kind of what actions lead to which
outcomes in kind of a good coverage of
all the states that might happen
but if you think about it in terms of
data sets on the scale of like
you know basically all the rest of
machine learning like you know
computer vision and lp and so on then
something that starts to come up is that
you can't possibly see even a small
sliver of everything but what you can
hope to do is you can hope to generalize
and you can hope to generalize not just
in the sense of like oh i've seen like a
very similar state
but you're gonna hope to generalize
across underlying factors of variation
and when that happens then you can hope
that your model will make sensible
conclusions
when it sees a mixture of factors of
variation that has never seen before but
where the individual values are
somewhere
and that's generalization and i think
that once we start looking at the world
this way
then it becomes much clearer where sort
of the
where the power of the learning machine
comes from it comes from
making these inferences and then
deciding that oh because i've seen this
thing over here and this thing over here
in this new state this other action
might lead to a good outcome even though
i've never seen that before
but we need to be in the mode of large
data sets and generalizations
actually for that to make sense
and maybe just to jump in on that so i
think another thing is that um i tend to
be
a big optimist like many of us so you
know optimism under uncertainty and i
think um
imitation learning the best you can hope
to do is to replicate the behavior of
the data set
but ideally and in our work and in a
number of the other papers that have
come out today
there's sort of safe policy improvement
style guarantees which say
if you really don't have enough data to
support any form of generalization
then you're going to revert back to a
behavioral policy but the hope is that
these type of offline approaches
can yield you know performances even
better assuming you can either make
these type of
inferences in generalization that serbia
is talking about and that you have
sufficient support
and i think to me that's the really
exciting thing is that we've seen so
much
benefit of imitation learning but many
cases we actually sort of within the
data
kind of have these latent better
policies where you already have support
and either by stitching together or
identifying successful trajectories
we can identify methods that we'll do
even better
so i don't know if all fear or thing you
if you want to add something and if not
that's also fine
sorry i i didn't hear the questions so i
guess i would skip uh uh so like i i was
a little late i i was just
right back from teaching uh there were
other questions after the class
so uh okay so maybe i'll go on to to my
next question i think this
this um uh tale does well from from
some of the responses uh so there is
this issue of of having state coverage
and there is this issue of being able to
to uncover these latent uh improved
policies from what you're given
from from the from the data um
and i'm wondering if if
given that a priori it's hard for us to
know uh for generalization like what
types
of what type of coverage we need in
order to be able to generalize well
or what type of of examples we need to
be able to
to find these latent policies um is the
answer to have more of an
iterative uh process to offline rl where
you're given a batch of data but then
you're
you're allowed to request more data um
in a
in a more specific specific way so not
just giving more data but
give me more data in these state action
pairs and sergey i think i alluded to
this a little bit in in his talk
and i'm wondering because most of the
the results that that have been
presented have been in the setting where
you're given the batch of data
and that's what you have to deal with
and i'm wondering how much
can we get out of that if we don't know
a priori what we're actually going to
need
without making relatively strong
assumptions
and feel free anyone to jump in
so i think it's a really interesting
question it came up this summer too at
the
theory of rl workshop at icml and shubra
had some really interesting comments
about how
in some of her interactions with
companies they would ask her how much
better would the policy be if i could
just get a little bit more data
where should i gather that i think in
the bandit setting um
maybe you could target different
demographics and it's easier to sort of
teleport to the states you need
that might be particularly particularly
realistic
my personal thought is it depends on the
domain and so i'm curious to hear from
others i think it's something like
robotics that seems pretty reasonable
um in some other cases like electronic
medical record systems
i think it's a big ask to sort of do a
lot of iterative updating and um
and for those scenarios that may be much
harder and it'll be nicer to sort of see
if one can have a significant
improvement um before collecting
additional data before disturbing the
workflow
um so i'm curious to see in other
domains maybe
i think in customer management amazon et
cetera it seems a little bit more
realistic in those scenarios
um but i'm curious what sega and tango
and authors think
i think that there's kind of maybe a
like a very pragmatic way to approach
that and then maybe a
more conceptual way so the very
pragmatic way to approach it is i
suspect that as long as our algorithms
are
kind of imperfect and fallible uh the
you know seemingly esoteric details of
the data composition
will continue to have a big effect and
it may even be
less uh less to do with can i kind of
get the perfect data
and more to do with certain very
very common data collection strategies
could be pathologically bad
so let me give an example um back when
we were doing that qg op thing that i
mentioned in my talk
one of the things we found that was
pathologically bad is if you just have
a hand designed policy that has no noise
if you have a hand-designed policy
that's just a little too deterministic
it's just like really really bad and if
you add even a little bit of noise
it becomes drastically less bad and
these kinds of little details are things
that might be good to
know because if someone is going to go
and collect a bunch of data
using some baseline system if that's an
easy change to make they might want to
be aware of it
but that's kind of the pragmatic side
the more conceptual side though is that
maybe echoing a little bit what emma is
getting at is that in a lot of
application domains the reason that we
want to do offline rl
is because running online experiments is
just really hard
either very dangerous or very expensive
or just in case of healthcare you just
like can't do it because it's like not
legal
uh and in those settings we really need
to be able to get
some baseline level of decent
performance because
before we can hope to deploy anything at
all and maybe that baseline level
performance can be obtained with a sort
of
heavy behavioral cloning style
regularization so maybe if you stay
close enough to the data you can at
least deploy something
that could be one way to go but we have
to be very conscious of that fact
because that's going to be a major
limitation
i guess uh i have um i don't have much
insight here but i guess i have a
confusion
so um so every time i was thinking about
this you know offline plus online
setting so when you say you have some
offline data and you start with online
exploration online kind of like
collecting data so it just sounds like
uh
uh the best strategy is a plus b you
just say you do whatever the best you
use online and then you start with that
policy and do online
uh rl so uh and so far i haven't seen
um you know maybe it's just my ignorance
but
i didn't see any method that can do
better than this
so of course this matter is not that
trivial to implement because
i think i've seen a few papers you know
in the past uh that
try to do this and then the problem is
that you're what you initialize right
whether you only utilize the policy
uh from the offline rl learning policy
or you want to utilize everything
so uh and if you only initialize the
policy but your
q function is random then um the
probability is not going to work because
your your policy will be destroyed even
your policy starting point policy
uh the initial policy is pretty
reasonable but the q function will
destroy the policy
and i think that's one of the reasons
why some of this learning from
demonstration approach
didn't work very well so but if you but
you know but i i think suppose you
somehow learn a good value function
using
some of the model based approach we are
doing all some of the model free
approach that circle
emma uh has been having done so and you
you start with a good
policy and good q function good model so
and so forth and you initiate all of
them
uh uh in the online r algorithm as i
suspect that's probably the best
uh you can do at least you know i i i'm
not sure but that's the best you can do
but that sounds like the best
uh we knew uh how to do uh
so that make it not very interesting so
uh
yeah that's my confusion i guess
if i can jump into this one um i'm
curious to hear that
uh many of the talks that they talked
about uh
of policy policy evaluation as an
important uh
inner loop right or something we need to
do to to to
address offline arrow now in online
learning you know there's also a
tradition of
um of being able to guarantee good
performance without
directly being able to evaluate right
sort of hedge your bets type of
approaches
uh and i think emma you mentioned
just you mentioned in healthcare for
example that we might
just need evaluation but i mean i
actually want i'm curious you know what
do we need
is is are we looking under the lamplight
by focusing on policy evaluation should
we just look for completely different
approaches
i think sergey mention this too in terms
of whether we really need to be
optimizing a lower bound
um my guess is that it depends on the
domain
um and the amount of risk that the you
know
that domain is willing to take um i
think
in some scenarios probably good lower
bounds or some sort of assurances are
really important
now you know whether all doctors are
familiar with q value
seems quite unlikely um but some sort of
you know maybe perturbation analysis
or susan short read and susan murphy and
joel pineau have some work on this
before
sort of looking at how much can you
perturb the the policy
um different interpretability to try to
understand
for doctors or other sort of domain
experts to understand how
you know stable these methods are those
i think might be really important for
being able to deploy them and rather
than strictly lower bounds on a
particular reward function
um but i do think probably some
assurances on
the likelihood of success and the extent
of success is probably pretty important
because
if it's only a very small improvement it
might not be worth
a change or the risk compared to if
there's a very large potential gain
either in cost or in terms of outcomes
yeah my opinion is that the focus on
off policy evaluation specifically has
been a bit of
an oval focus in terms of uh
like so what we want to do with this
down the line like in my experience and
like simulated robotics and uh
a lot of uh like recommendation systems
what we really want is just
some sort of off policy selection
algorithm we don't care
much about what the value is it's just
that you know we have a bunch of
hypo parameters and we learn about a
bunch of jobs now we can only
run a few on the robots and uh which
ones are we going to choose
on the other hand maybe in health and
education domains uh like emma mentioned
interpretability is more important than
knowing like what is the exact
value this policy is going to get like
what's more important is
why is it doing what it's doing and uh
can we is there some way to get the
client to unders to have confidence in
the model
as opposed to just saying well we did a
bunch of these low bounds analysis and
we think it'll be likely about this
value
i think that there's also another
element here which is that if you're
doing policy optimization while you
could have evaluation as an inner loop
because you get to pick the policy that
can make the evaluation problem much
much
easier so asking to evaluate some
arbitrary policy
could be i mean it could be essentially
impossible if you get to pick the policy
uh then you could essentially play this
game where you find
the best policy for which you can
confidently say that it's good and
that's probably a much easier evaluation
problem in
many ways uh i want to also resonate a
lot with
what others said right so if you think
about like supervised learning what we
do right training
validation and test and so far i think a
lot of times all we have been talking
about
is only evaluation for testing we're
learning for training
but we have like ignored a lot about
like the problem of
validation itself and presumably like
when you do ope
uh one of the purposes is like for
testing but
another application is that it can help
you to do
uh validations like cross validation
hyper parameter tuning
model selection so on so forth but now
like sometimes you need to just
think about it like ope is just one way
of doing it
like you could have like attacked the
problem with model selection like
directly
and this is related to like uh you know
this very recent result which emma
uh have mentioned a couple of times uh
like
and the toxins almost like it turns out
that under certain scenarios like
doing cross-validation like directly
with like
q values is in some sense much
simpler and gives you way stronger
guarantees than just our policy evaluate
each policy
and then pick the best so i think we
should like
maybe think in terms of like what we
want those methods to do in terms
instead of like just focusing on you
know improving
those methods themselves yeah and also
if i may um
the policy evaluation problem is
important in the sense that um if you
think of the connection to causal
effect estimation it's essentially the
same problem and we know that
in statistics and all these supply
domains uh causal effect estimation is
one of the core problems
so you can solve a policy rl or policy
evaluation
uh from observational data well enough
then i think that will also have a lot
of
impact on other apply domains and apply
statistics
i think my question is in some sense is
what if we can't solve op lihong should
we should we look for things
i like nun's point right uh what if it's
really really hard to solve op
maybe we're just making things harder
for us and and especially that now that
lee home brought up the you know the
cultural influence compoundedness
i i'm sort of a little bit pessimistic
in that you know
causal influence itself like just for
one step right
it's already like a ridiculously hard
problem and there's a whole area like
devoted to it
and then we're adding like multi-steps
plus the cursive horizon to it
um i don't know like how
i don't know how optimistic everyone
else is about
this yeah
well in the one step problem um if we
don't have an observer confounders
i think the problem is relatively uh
easy to solve
um i guess a lot of the headaches come
from the hidden variables
so we have to use all kinds of uh
assumptions to do causal inference
but if we are making a markovian
assumption which is analog
in the real scenario i think a lot of
things can be done although it's not
trivial
but we are having an observed confounder
then i agree that this is really uh
a very uh intimidating problem to look
at
but p i know people are starting to look
at this problem
there's a nice tutorial this summer from
elias byron mom um
about sort of called laurel at icml
where he's one of the people
um that's really thinking about this
area as i'm sure many of the panelists
know
actually i'm pretty optimistic about op
i mean in the sense that i think there's
been
a lot of work over the last five you
know four to five years and there's also
some really cool work from nathan
talis's group
that takes more of sort of an
econometrics
type approach and very doubly robust i
think that we're starting to have pretty
good theory for this setting i think we
could do a little bit more answer better
empirical results but i think we're
getting pretty close on that side
but i think that we're not um yet i
think there's still more open questions
on the optimization side
i just want to mention that i think in
terms of whether we need it um
one paper i found really interesting on
this front recently um
was some work by akshay and me and
others
which was looking at whether you could
do model selection
um and one of the really cool ideas in
that paper it was an icml paper
is to say that maybe you'd be able to
select but you wouldn't actually know
exactly how good that bound was so you
wouldn't be able to get a lower bound
but sort of provably it would still be
the best you could do they have this
nice trick about assuming they sort of
monotonic
monotonicity in terms of the bias across
your different estimators
um so i think that's a really
interesting question about whether in
some cases even provably you might be
able to do the best
when you're selecting among a set of
policies or
you know a set of estimators but you
wouldn't be able to know exactly what
that value is and so maybe in those
cases that would also be
um a satisfying uh answer to this
question
maybe one thing i might add also in
regard to this like
there's this this notion which i think
you guys were getting at that
basically op sort of looks like a
problem that requires answering counter
factuals which
due to a whole host of causality reasons
might be essentially impossible from
observational data
but uh i think one very important detail
is that if we are concerned with
optimization
it's okay to answer i don't know so the
really bad thing is to say
i know the answer and this is great when
in fact this is not great
but if you have a system that can say i
don't know that is
that is probably actually enough to do
very effective policy learning
and that might actually be kind of the
you know the secret that makes us all
manageable i'm not
sort of causality complete so to speak
i have a small comment or question
or i don't know how to phrase that but
maybe maybe i have some issue with this
kind of thinking
uh because i think that uh we are often
forgetting that we are putting
a lot of assumptions in anything that we
do
uh so no matter what like uh you can't
get causality from nothing
you put causality into the model in some
way this way or another way
and uh there is no you know free lunch
here
uh so just saying nothing or just just
uh returning the answer i don't know
uh if we are frank to ourselves we
should always do that
right because we have no idea about how
the data was
really generated in a complicated
scenario and whatnot
so uh all of the results are going to be
qualified
uh where you want to have some you know
like
uh reside that provides some sort of
guarantees uh
they're going to be qualified with some
assumptions and then the discussion
should be
about whether those assumptions are
reasonable or not
but at the same time i agree with that
like
enriching uh the the
uh the things that you can return like
saying i don't know
or or like resorting to some standard
behavior for example so changing the
problem
may actually be uh be a good direction
to go into
i just wanted to kind of like clarify a
little bit about this
oh thank you you're muted thank you
yeah it doesn't look like you're muted
but we can't hear you
i think it's his mic is has some problem
you cannot hear me oh it's fine now okay
good
so i guess um um i think this uncertain
qualification
just drove me crazy so uh about that
like uh so i think i know lee hong i've
read the quick paper you know
very carefully and uh and i was trying
to extend it to non-linear multiples
uh in the last uh uh last few months and
it was pretty difficult
so you got into the same problem as in
non-linear deep reinforcement so just
when you have non-linear neural networks
it's very hard to do a certain
qualification
so um that you know to me that's the
at least the the main question i
couldn't uh uh
resolve like uh like i don't know how to
do uncertain qualifications for
the models so um and not
for the dynamics not for the q function
so and so forth so
um that seems to be the one of the major
question
uh that we are facing which is not
necessarily a real question and that
makes it kind of like annoying because
you have to go to the uh the island
clarification
uh literature and see what are there and
they are not that much there i think
uh especially for out of domain and
certain classification
so probably that's uh that's open
direction that
deserves a little more attention only in
my opinion
yeah the two kinds of uncertainty uh
perhaps you what you're
thinking is the approximation error type
of a certainty
as opposed to statistical uncertainty is
it
oh no i'm not i'm uh referring to the
the past
uh uh the the statistical one the
so you assume that you have uh um you
have realizability let's say
but you just have a domain shifter so
for example you learn your
dynamics on some data and then
you test on some data point that is not
from the same distribution
then what's the uncertainty for your uh
prediction
so and for em although you can do that
pretty well this just involves something
like axed
uh measured under some norm and that's
the certain quantification measure
uh and for non-linear modes we don't
know how to do it
a little bit uh a simple covering
argument just give you this
sorry i mean like maybe you're not happy
with the covering argument maybe what
you're saying is that
uh yeah we do have some tools but you're
not really happy with the tools the
covering argument
i'm not sure is uh the having not so
harming argument so what are covering
like using metric entropy and whatnot
uh maybe i'm just amazing something
obvious
about it but i like that example but
non-linear models uncertainty
uh they are fairly general uh and maybe
there's a problem with them
that they're gonna be super conservative
because of that
i totally agree that we don't have good
tools one of the way to do it is the
uh the irregular dimension which i uh
uh sorry i didn't know what you were
referring to but the euro dimension is
another alternative
but that's also very conservative um
so you are requiring uh that any two
models
needs to agree on your uh new example
uh so that you can be certain about it
and that sounds just a
way too conservative
tangy are you more my my i would be more
optimistic that we'll be able to get
them first for dynamics models compared
to q functions
uh but what is your thoughts or or
others too i mean i generally feel like
it's more likely we can get good
uncertainty quantification first from
the models
rather than all the way across the queue
yeah yeah i
agree yeah i think for dynamics is
easier but that becomes a surprise
learning problem it's not like rl
so i think that's the catch
yeah oh by the way like let's talk about
another cache there
so even for dynamics if you really have
correlated data
i think that you're doomed with your
uncertainty quantification again
because you have no idea about the
mixing times and without knowing the
mixing times
you won't get nothing and to estimate
mixing times
from data from a single pass we know
that that
is like i mean it is
it is it is something you can try to do
but uh
without assuming any extra structure uh
there's no luck there yeah uh so just
i'm just gonna jump in here
yeah um so scott nikom i think is trying
to say something
scott if you can oh i did have a
question although i guess
it goes back to ope um if so i don't
want to take us too far off but
uh i guess it's a question nominally for
sergey but i'd be interested to hear
what other people think too
um so sergey had mentioned before that
um
you know one one way of kind of making
opi easier
is you know thinking intelligently about
selecting policies that we actually want
to evaluate
so you know maybe looking for the best
policy that we can confidently say
something about
so i just wondered if uh because there
hasn't been a ton of work in this area
if
sergey or anyone else has ideas about
what the right way to do
that kind of search or proposal
of policies is well i actually think
that a lot a lot of the work that was
discussed
in the morning session does basically
get at this point although i'll be at
someone indirectly
where if you are pessimistic in some way
and evaluate your policy you know for
instance with the method that thing you
described or the
the method i described in my talk it is
kind of having this effect of punting on
the
on the stuff that you can't evaluate so
if you sort of assign a very low value
to things that you're not sure about
that's kind of the same as saying that
you don't know because
your policy just won't go there so so in
effect you're just saying if you don't
know what's going to happen
just just don't just don't basically and
that's a decent rule of thumb and i
think so i think these methods are you
know they're not exactly doing
this but i think they're kind of
actually going in that direction and we
might see
further evolution on these ideas as
leading to that outcome
yeah fair thanks for so to follow up on
that a little bit
um if we think about this more uh
iterative
uh method that we're discussing before
how do you differentiate between actual
low value and and
don't know uh value if you were to for
instance use whatever q function you
learned
to inform future data gathering
maybe i'll take on that question and
also take
combine it with some comments java made
earlier and turn that into a new
question for emma
so uh i think in general like for
example if we think about the you know
the
the the duality method that over was
talking about or
in general this marginalized uh
marginalized important
sampling methods i think the answer is
in general you don't know
unless you have some strong assumptions
on your
uh function transmitter which goes you
know somewhat
back to childbirth one right and and one
comparison i always would like to make
in terms of our current status of ope
is to compare how you can do testing in
supervised learning right
how much data does it take to do testing
supervised learning
like one right or oh like one over small
square or something like that
how much data does it take for now if i
want to do something like marginalized
important assembly
well if you're using internet i'm
solving another deep learning problem
on my test set like that you mean
in order to satisfy the like reliability
assumptions required by my theory
right so on the other hand you know
there's this good old
you know sequentially important sampling
that gets rid of this issue but
really can only evaluate policies that
are extremely close to your
behavior policy but uh i mean like
overly hong
i have been sort of like owing to this
mis regime where i think am i still like
looking at
is i i'm somewhat like
kind of swing back and forth between
these and
i would like to hear emma's thought on
like the choices between these two and
also everyone else um i guess i'll say
two things
um uh it's interesting that both the
method i presented today
and our paper on circle policy policy
gradient from last summer
both are mis so they're both doing
through stationary importance sampling
methods um
they do rely on the domain and the
representation one has been
marked off um and i think that in in in
reality for a lot of case at least some
of the healthcare data that we've looked
at i don't think we're using
representations yet which satisfy that
um but i think that's a big limitation
because i think we're almost definitely
getting into the specification
maybe in terms of in general which of
the two are more promising i think
partly it depends how well we can
estimate those stationary distributions
assuming we're willing to make the
markov assumption
but also to go to pablo's previous
question i think in the method like the
method that i described today which is
sort of a model free
um analog to mopo and to morel um
these all three of these methods
maintain a direct
estimate of sort of what things are
considered to be close or far some of
them are more soft
but um some of them present you
essentially a hard label of you know an
indicator of are you passive threshold
or not
so at least you'd have a labeling of
every state action pair
which is unknown um and i think that
would help a little bit in terms of
trying to quantify is it unknown or is
it bad
because you could use that information
for later or build sort of some
approximation of the space in which it
is unknown
but going forward i think it's a really
interesting question which of these
types of approaches is going to be
most effective um i do just want to
mention that nathan callus has some
really nice work
with masatoshi and showing that if
you're willing to make the markup
assumption you're just sort of
provably much more efficient which maybe
isn't a surprise but it's nice to see
the gap between
is methods and stationary is and you
really do get a substantial gain
if you can make the markup assumption
all right thank you so we're a little
over time i think we can go a little
more i just wanted to ask one
um higher level question and maybe
trying to bring things back uh into what
emma was saying
that offline rl perhaps is one of the uh
most promising avenues for trying to
bring rl into the real world where
we're able to access data that people
have been gathering without perhaps
rl in mind and provide new new guidance
provide some type of evaluation or
perhaps new
new new policies for them to implement
and what i'm wondering is
um say somebody has some data or is able
to acquire data
what can we as the arel community um
give as as insights or or best practices
in terms of gathering this data
so that down the road it will be more
amenable to these types of methods
if any i think one of the things i would
say if um
if you can record the probabilities of
uh taking the actions under the states
um that's not always
probably in many web companies it's
logged but it's not always logged and
we're actually doing some new criminal
justice work where
we're like we have to walk this we have
to log sort of the probability of
sending out text messages and stuff
um because often for different
subpopulations you'll have different
probabilities
and trying to infer it later leads to
all sorts of
errors and estimations and in many cases
we really do know it and so if you do
know it and you have access to all the
variables that are used to make those
decisions
so we can avoid the compounding problem
i think that's huge in terms of us being
able to make reliable inferences later
maybe this is a little bit of a
non-answer but to turn this around a bit
maybe something i might say is i think
we as the reinforced learning community
really need to work hard towards methods
that don't place any
constraints or restrictions uh for the
simple reason that essentially
the fewer can the fewer considerations
you have to have in mind when collecting
your data
the more your method will be able to use
lots of data and and
you know the one thing we've seen again
again is that if you have a method that
can use lots of data
then it will generally work much better
so the more unstructured the more open
world the more you can grab stuff from
the net
the better the thing is going to be so
this is definitely a huge issue right
now but
i think it's something we can make
progress towards i think it's really
important to take that seriously
it's easy to kind of ignore that when
we're working on like you know kind of
benchmark problems
as we all do but we need to really be
thinking about that more i think
yeah i guess for me i also think of this
kind of like
offline data is more kind of like
somebody give you
and you just receive it passively
because if
you are able to kind of like guide them
how to collect the data then why not
just run online rl right so
of course there could be some situations
that you still want to
do it in smaller number of runs i think
somebody call it deplo
deployment time or something like that
right so you want to do the
the the collection data in phases you
know in fewer number phases but i guess
it's less clear to me why you don't want
to do online rl if you can
already tell somebody to collect data in
some special way
well so i'm thinking in particular for
the cases that emma was saying with
health for instance right
where it's not easy for to just go and
run your rl algorithm on people
but if you can give guidelines to the
health practitioners
in terms of how they collect data and
what type of data they collect and
perhaps what types of strategies
they use for um
their patients i know joel pino had some
work about a decade ago on
um depression and the sequence of of
treatments given to patients um and that
was
dealing with with offline data but they
were starting to to try to provide
guidance to the practitioners into
what types of sequences of treatments
would lead to
um to better insights into uh future
policies
but these treatments are on the patients
yes
you have to change the pa the treatment
that the doctor
uh originally gave to them well so for
new patients right so
they have a particular in this example
they have a particular test that sort of
um places them in some type of
characteristic for the type of
uh problem they're facing and based on
that
the practitioners have a strategy for
prescribing
medicine and the the point of this work
was
to suggest perhaps this is the not the
right sequence that would maximize
success and or uh maximize the amount of
information you can gather from this
data i see so i guess you're saying that
you want to not just to try
arbitrary policy learn from the rl but
you try some policy that is kind of a
mixture of the human policy
with a little bit of preservation maybe
diversity or something like like that so
that
that well yes i mean so how how can we
help
the non-oral people help us get the
right data so that then we can help them
back again with with better policies
i might have to say something about this
uh the question is how to collect data
but
uh the initial data is something but
when you produce a policy you will uh
want to gather new data on this and i'm
thinking for example about
medicine but the overall application
domains where
it would be true the thing is that uh
you can
give you want to apply a reinforcement
learning policy on real human
uh i mean on patients but it will be
more like a kind of
help for the doctor and the doctor can
give feedback
on the decision uh provided by the
policy
and this human feedback can be very
useful
for training a new algorithm and it can
provide some information
it's not easily quantified but the human
feedback can be very
very important and this is this loop
between the machine and the human
but we should also try to extract some
to provide maybe the next policy
yeah i think that's a really great point
and um this there's a lot of work
uh not necessarily in rl a little bit in
rl but of this human in the loop
learning which i think will become more
and more um
pressing as we start trying to deploy
these methods in the real world and with
affecting humans in in real ways so
perhaps that's a good
uh way to transition into the gather
town where we can continue these
interesting discussions um i believe the
link
should uh be available to all of you and
i think it was
yes the simon's institute just put the
link um so
we will regather and gather town thank
you everyone
the speakers in particular for for their
interesting talks
and thank you everyone for the questions
and uh
thought-inspiring discussions
see you soon thank you pablo thank you
all see you
goodbye
you